the president in wisconsin doing damage
control on his bipartisan trillion
dollar
infrastructure package dot dot after he
almost blew up the deal by trying to
appease members of the squad with the
promise of trillions more in spending
the president changing his tune today
this bipartisan breakthrough is a great
deal for the american people
not just for folks in cities not just
for red states or blue states but for
everybody
i know that neither democrats nor
republicans get everything they
not all that i propose but that's what
our economy is all about
that's what it means to compromise and
reach consensus and that's what every
in the heart of every democracy of
course the far left's furious with the
deal
aoc and her fellow climate crusaders
actually showed up outside the white
house and called biden
a coward we have a critical mass of
people saying
no climate no you we got to
push all right dana
i thought last week that
we had a deal biden came out he even
whispered that he had a deal
that's right and then all of a sudden
there's no deal and he's scrambling and
what is happening
well i think that democrats are in
disarray and
i think it's pretty funny that many of
them believe that the republicans are
now in the hot seat because they have to
decide if they're going to
support this deal no republicans already
said we'll be willing to do this
deal and then two hours later joe biden
said i will veto that if i also don't
get all this human infrastructure at
four trillion dollars
look they've treated bernie sanders like
he was a crazy uncle for so long but now
he's actually chairman of the budget
committee
and he's saying six trillion dollars and
the left isn't going to
let up on this so actually the
republicans could just sit back
eat some popcorn and watch watch this
situation now the one thing the
republicans do have to think about is
a lot of these things sound very popular
and when you do the initial poll
let's remember this from the 2016
election or 2020
um well probably 2016 as well if you say
do you think everyone should have free
health care
do you think people should be able to
have free college do do you think this
and the numbers will be like yeah people
should be able to do that people should
well do you think you should pitch in do
you think you should pay for that do you
think you should and then they answer
like oh wait no and like
that dramatically drops the messaging on
that for republicans is a little bit
more difficult but
i mean they're gonna have to they're
gonna have to do their best so katie
does this prove that joe biden's a
puppet to the far left because every
time they scream he just jerks himself
back
into their position and we don't have a
deal well he totally gave them an
opportunity
to be controlled by the left on this
issue because he made this odd statement
that he would veto his own bill last
week and then over the weekend
to release this multi-paragraph
statement trying to backtrack on why
that wasn't a good idea
we're going to have to see how this
plays out on capitol hill mitch
mcconnell hasn't exactly said
what they're going to do yet on this i
think we should look forward a little
bit because democrats and republicans
all like to spend money but are they
going to actually be able to implement
these projects there's a roadblock
standing in front
of joe biden's infrastructure bill when
it comes to the environment so
trump talked about this all the time you
can't build roads and bridges and
infrastructure if you have these
burdensome environmental regulations
on the books there's a law called the
national environmental policy act of
1969.
and uh remember you know it remember
shovel ready jobs well a lot of that
didn't happen
and a lot of money got wasted because of
that so i don't think they're really
thinking about the implementation of
this and the consequences of a lack of
actual infrastructure
either so jessica is biden not the deal
maker
we thought he was here i don't think
that
joe biden has failed at all thus far
certainly in getting what he wants he
has his 1.9 trillion dollar american
rescue package this is a core
component of the american jobs act and
mitch mcconnell said over the weekend
if the reconciliation bill isn't
necessarily tied to this
republicans should be for this everybody
wants infrastructure and certainly
uh republicans that are in states with
crumbling bridges we have a crumbling
building in florida now that
you know unrelated it's a private
building i understand i'm just saying
there are disasters
all around but it's not like part of
infrastructure plan
okay i'm not saying it's going to fund
surfside i'm just saying that people are
surrounded by things that are broken
and republicans and democrats want to
fix them you know what else is crumbling
your ivory tower coming crashing down
my degrees are a great government money
but
putting aside the private versus public
infrastructure
issue joe biden has gotten what he
wanted and i think we all remember when
the squad was like
oh i don't know if we're going to vote
for nancy pelosi a speaker and then they
all lined up and they voted for nancy
pelosi
they fall in line and bernie sanders has
also fallen in line throughout his
entire
50-year curmudgeonly career so i think
that joe biden will be able
to get this done with the spending bill
but can republicans trust democrats not
to
no then spend they can't so that's the
democrat that's what i always say greg
when you saw the video of aoc
screaming at biden with the bullhorn
from outside the white house
what'd you think of that i thought
insurrection oh
insurrection you know um what's the use
of infrastructure if you can't use it
with these gas prices is anybody going
to be on the highway
have you seen how high the gas prices
are they're like
they're insane by the way because i i
don't know what's going to happen with
this thing
but you know whispering joe did just
bomb a bunch of places
the media didn't really seem to mind
because foreign death is preferable to
mean tweets about cnn
right that's the eternal irony is that
you know
so you don't have to deal with that
abrasive personality anymore and joe was
so kind
bomb away maybe he was bombing to
distract
yes from his failed infrastructure deal
yes
now i'm a cnn contributor those are the
kind of things they said about trump for
four years all right
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else